I think something that I really
appreciated that you said in the book
that I've learned from you is that that
this this happiness pot of gold is not
at the end of the rainbow of achievement
but rather it's along the journey in the
present moment along the journey it's
almost as a mindset along the journey
yeah it's so so one of the biggest myths
of the modern world is that and I say
that with love and respect which
productized everything we've even
productized happiness it's like it's
really really funny because that pot of
gold that's called happiness was
actually at the beginning of the journey
so so you were born happy right every
child you've ever seen every infant
you've ever seen if they get their basic
needs for survival they're happy right
and then we run out of happiness it's
not the other way around right but yet
because everything to us now is sort of
the material the material view of the
world we think that happiness is
something that we should acquire we
should strive for we should work hard to
to achieve it it's almost like we've
earned it like we've done our share of
hard work and now we deserve to be happy
when you were a child you didn't have to
do anything to be happy right you didn't
even need anything from outside you to
be happy
now that myth is in my view the biggest
enemy of happiness in the modern world
it is it's almost as if we come to a
point where we don't think we deserve it
anymore as a matter of fact a lot a lot
of us even believe that if we are happy
we're doing something wrong
maybe we're not trying hard enough right
you know some some in some northern
European culture you know is so against
the idea that if you smile at someone in
the street they'll think that
something's wrong with you right in in a
very interesting way if you if you go to
work and appear to be very happy your
boss will go like are we paying him too
much you know it's like what's what's
wrong with this right it's like we've
started to tell ourselves no no we
should not be happy and so we started to
delay it we started to say when I have
achieved the other more important prize
jeez then I have earned the right to be
happy what what priority is more
important it's like when you when you
really think about it aren't you trying
to achieve all of this so that you
become happy so why why the middleman
why do you have to take a step on the
way why don't you just solve directly
for happy